hey guys we hope you're safe we hope
you're healthy welcome back to versus
one even though we're practicing social
distancing that doesn't mean you can't
form new connections we are proud to
partner with bumble for this special
virtual episode or versus one we use the
bumble app and they're in app video chat
feature to bring one lady together with
20 lucky guys and to see if we can find
a perfect match
and just like us they're looking forward
to the time when they can once again be
together in person but until that time
stay safe out there and enjoy this video
here they come hey I'm Lisa Pinto I'm 21
years old and I currently am a student
in Los Angeles yeah what is your dating
life been like durian quarantine
non-existent owl 8 and 21 okay he has
some nice hair he's a singer piano
player I'm tryna learn piano
6 foot great actively a bully oh okay
okay
Oh
like being right boom one I'm gonna have
to swipe left I'm so sorry
David Alan are you in here oh you're so
funny
okay spikes cowboy did you know that
Krampus is just some mark bet he's 6 1
nice he's cute I like him I'm gonna
swipe right nice film composer nice a
master of oversharing sometimes cries
while listening to finding me I like
that I like your profile picture you
look studious
all right I'll sweep right okay okay
favorite quality in a person ambition or
a favorite calling a person humor me -
OH - yes understand this yes spongebob
you got dog food you're six eight yes
Jesus and you're cute thank you
- truce one light one of these I'm a
semi-pro soccer player I'm gonna have to
swipe left on you Stephen I'm so sorry
yes the third picture of you in that
costume everything that I feel like when
we get along and you're cute so I
misspoke right Brian I feel like we
would get along more as friends than
romantically go you're an artist student
a traveler a Christian love you like
good food a nice drink me too I would
definitely swipe right on you you're
really cute
so are you shirtless with all of your
friends no yeah also a great on you
Jason Joanie you're just cute as hell so
I'm gonna swipe right nice Evan okay 22
wait your Costa Rican yeah I'm actually
I have family from Costa Rica nice you
seem super sweet but like I would want
to be your friend not
you oh yeah I could say okay thank you
though you're welcome
honestly I was pretty nervous about the
whole experience but it was honestly a
lot of fun whenever it gets a first date
doctor quarantine with her is gonna be a
one lucky man you'll send the same first
message to every single cent okay let me
put my glasses on for this so I can see
haha success is making your family proud
not just how you make money but how you
love respect and devote yourself to them
success is being a good you are oh this
is a paragraph that's something I think
about a lot actually first success for
me means being able to support myself my
family my friends I want to leave
something behind that can be remembered
and appreciate I think success to me
means reaching a point in my life where
I'm not bothered to compare myself to
other people okay okay okay first person
I eliminated with Sam
like I agree with the whole thing I I
just feel like there were more details I
guess responses Chris you said setting
the best example I can for everyone I
journey I think if we all work together
we can succeed together I love that I
think we all need to work together but
is that the only thing you can find I
think success can be in any aspect of
life and every minute of every day so
you know you should just be doing what's
the best you can to be the best version
of yourself okay the next one is Alec
[Music]
cannon okay
I'm sorry Kevin that's all right she
don't want to go further and that's
totally fine there's nine billion of
those human beings out there I have to
understand a nut everyone's gonna be
into me and she has to go after whatever
she's into this is called the video chat
or crib tour so Lisa's going to video
call you guys and Bumble is their own
really clipping the room right now oh
yeah
oh here's a secret here's a secret your
room is you should always be clean oh so
your mother lime green
[Music]
my roommate and the back loves it though
drew great the snake bro
scared of snakes it's understandable
it's one way or the other
David
[Music]
I'm sorry okay it's okay it's okay
I think me sprinting to my roof it's not
really a good look but again you miss
hundred percent of the shots you don't
take so it's okay don't explain I don't
wanna I've had my snake since I was a
kid he's been with me all my life
growing up so it's uh he's an important
part of my life and I was pretty
surprised how non-competitive the
atmosphere was it wasn't toxic and I
thought there might have been some toxic
energy there's so many guys for 20
versus one all right
this brings us to our finals no way
that's crazy
[Music]
we're extremely limited during
quarantine you gotta can't really see
each other except virtually but I don't
know maybe like we can both make
sandwiches over the phone and do some we
can like go through each other's
pantries virtually you know I'm saying
see what we got in like you can put a
little recipe together
I say we still get dressed up candles
shut those up I don't know I think any
relationship you just need to build to
help you like kind of foundation just
getting to know each other and
everything like that so just talking
simple talking maybe I'll sing to you
over the camera get to know you better
talk music a little more I like this
that's all I'm saying and you can set up
zoom and you've got Netflix party and
poke at the same time yo on the
projector
I see where you're going there yeah
quarantine cuca I like it except your
food would come out really good in my
food would come out like trash it's a
collaborative effort we're gonna work
together on this movie we're ultimately
narrow it down top snake but first just
eliminate two guys Aiden I'm sorry no
it's all good
thanks for the opportunity thanks for
keeping me till the finals that that
means a lot to me my boys peace and
blessings guys good luck much love
Malcolm
okay okay okay hey it's all good it's
all good I'm not sure made it to the top
three can't complain
put my best foot forward and it just
didn't pan out so at least you seem like
a great girl would have loved to get to
know her
Omar I just think it was great that we
had this opportunity to connect and
explore given the present circumstances
so it's all good
Jonah you're just goofy you're just
funny as hell and I really like that
you've been making me laugh this whole
time my cheeks hurt I can't stop smiling
and Elijah I feel like we get each other
on like we both are like religious and
how you're explaining your house and
stuff and the date the date got me oh my
gosh this is like the end no matter what
you choose I think that we know that
it's the best choice for you so you both
made this experience worthwhile and fun
so I think if I were to go on a date
with one of you the person's date that
caught my eye more was Elijah Jonah it
was a great experience
um the best man won obviously clearly oh
really
really glad to be a part of it this is a
really great experience honestly I
wouldn't leave y'all to it - exactly
so did you think you were gonna win I
didn't think so actually I did this
thinking it was just gonna be a fun time
but a cute girl came on and I was like
whoa maybe I can win
well I at some point I don't want to do
this now but I'll get we can get each
other's numbers
[Music]
huge thanks to bumble for partnering
with us on this episode we want to
remind you guys that during this time
it's better to stay safe and date from
home spend this time getting to know
somebody so that by the time you have
your first date it doesn't feel like a
first date be sure to download the
bumble app using the link in the
description below thanks for watching